running is a big part of our life here
and hokey lot of our training we do is
under dirt roads on the old trails that
my ancestors ran on say it goes back
into history where our ancestors were
messengers village to village that's
what the rotors represent they run for
the strength and health for the village
members and that's what we're trying to
develop here with the cross country
program to sustain that and to keep our
culture alive keep our ceremonies alive
there's a really deep spiritual purpose
behind it and it's something that our
communities are problem
[Music]
the Hopi people have been here for
centuries
[Music]
the Hopi reservation Hopi high school
were located on the north eastern part
of Arizona where you live on the
plateaus a summertime it gets very hot
it's very dry the environment here is
very harsh then it's very good for
developing strength physical strength
the mental strength and spiritual side
of running the young men are instructed
to take our prayers to the very springs
that we have around the villages and the
purpose behind that is to bring the
moisture back to the villages the Hopi
word for people all around the world is
soft koa single my grandfather always
taught me about running for all the
people running happily that's all
motivates me I first started coaching
here in 1987 our cross-country Chiefs
very well known for all the state titles
that we've won you know we've won 27
consecutive state titles now and I think
it speaks for itself
we won in 1990 and then from there you
know it's stuck ah
year after year after year there's not
much teens in United States that can say
they have them estate titles in a row as
a Hopi nation our communities are proud
of that pretty much Ronnie's been a part
of my life since early childhood here at
the village our elders used to preach to
us a long time that we need to go out
get educated and then come back home to
your reservation and help young people
and that's kind of what was my
motivation is coming back and just
working with these Hopi kids there are
real good kids hey guys you guys start
running these need to start running a
whole whole course don't walk and then
be ready for the next race guys start
working hard cross-country is a distance
event it's a 5,000 meter race or so you
got to train these kids to be strength
runners but at the same time having that
speed also I tell my kids cross-country
isn't easy
our program is weren't going hard every
day and your body's gonna hurt and you
expect that hurts compete
[Music]
you want to build them to be a family in
a brotherhood so that they are
accountable for each other so when it
comes to training when it comes to
racing coming to you everything within
their lives they care for each other
cross-country appears very special we
run as a family we run for everyone we
work for each other feels like I'm a
part of something really big and I need
to do my best to make this school proud
this is the start of the cross-country
season we want to welcome all the teams
that are here to a movie it's gonna be a
jamboree I hope you were not home but
that is what we use for when things get
tough when things get very hard
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
long with us like a motive that gets us
all going gives us hyped up you know one
two three no with that our elderlies
tell us to really deep down deep find
that inner strength to get through the
ceremony in this case get through the
run through the meat man I'm I'm on fire
it up
go get Tom good job get your look my
journal is going you know not I'm just
right there on the under course with the
kids and I'm just yelling it I'm you
know I'm just like go on you know you
got a gold man come on all right hey you
got a dig down here wake it up wake up
now I love it you know I love that
competition here in hope you do have
that strong support for our program
because extended family members friends
they were once runners too we look at
writing as a way of life for us it's in
them it's in them they're naturally
talented distance runners okay let's go
good job man
[Music]